houston police department announced on
friday night that an investigation has
been launched into texans quarterback
deshaun watson a criminal complaint
filed no names released and this comes
only days after attorney tony busby who
represents 21 of the individuals who
have sued deshaun watson said he wasn't
going to share evidence with the houston
police department citing biases relating
both to him and to rusty hardin who
represents deshaun watson hardin for his
part issued a statement saying we
welcome this long overdue development
there's the statement from houston
police that popped up late friday
afternoon early friday evening no
further comment but they do comment on
the fact that the investigation has been
sparked there's hardin's statement we
welcome this long overdue development
now we will learn the identity of at
least one accuser we will fully
cooperate with the houston police
department now we will fully cooperate
to me chris means that if they want to
talk to deshaun watson he's going to
show up and talk he'll wave his fifth
amendment right against
self-incrimination and answer questions
and
we don't know what will happen with that
process and again the bar is much higher
in criminal courts beyond a reasonable
doubt that is the standard that must be
met and prosecutors have very broad
discretion
when it comes to who gets charged who
doesn't get charged a lot of prosecutors
won't pursue a case that they think they
may lose they don't like to lose others
will pursue a case just to make a
statement even if they know it's going
to be difficult to get a conviction and
when it comes down to it if the
complaining party tells a very
compelling story that doesn't have a lot
of holes and if the thought is desean
watson when it comes down to it won't
get on the witness stand and subject
himself to withering cross-examination
at trial which many criminal defendants
most criminal defendants will not do
that
maybe they decide to roll the dice i
don't know and i'm not going to pretend
to know and i think the truth is no one
knows where this is going to go but it
changes things the fact that someone has
filed a criminal complaint against
desean watson
changes things because as these civil
lawsuits were piling up over the last
three weeks chris one of the things that
people
reacting to this
were saying was why didn't anybody go to
the cops well now someone did
so
that argument's off the table yeah why
why now why does someone go to it now i
mean just what's your thought there for
we don't know enough we don't know
enough to speculate on that right is it
is it one of the 21
looking to bolster yeah her case
or or is it somebody else who hasn't
sued who just has decided you know what
go this way
i'm more comfortable now i wasn't
comfortable before this is a very
difficult personal challenging sensitive
topic yeah and a lot of people who
do believe that they've been violated in
some way in this type of a context won't
do anything about it
could it be and we again we don't know
could it be that someone
who feels
that all of these other individuals
are doing something
i'm going to do something and i'm not
going to file a lawsuit i don't care
about that it really isn't about the
money for me it's about justice and i'm
going to choose to pursue my justice by
filing a criminal complaint we don't
know at this point whether it's one of
the 21 yeah or whether it's somebody
else if it's somebody else
i think that
on the surface just knowing that if we
ever do know that if it's not one of the
ones who have sued and if there's
somebody who never sues
that instantly carries
a different level of credibility in the
eyes of most people i would say okay you
you think that's more damn damning to to
desean watson if you got somebody like
that i think at a very superficial level
yeah without knowing any of the facts
without having a chance to investigate
or hear what the person's story is or
where the the gaps may be or the
weaknesses may be or
just the fact that somebody who chooses
not to sue at a time when the train is
rolling with 21 cars on it to not add
car 22 but instead
go
to the houston police department and
file a criminal complaint if if that's
the case we just don't know i don't know
but but it would be odd to say the least
if
one of the 21
represented by tony busby just days
after buzzby says
i'm not giving anything to the houston
police department because they have some
sort of a bias against me and maybe a
biased in favor of rusty harden who
represents watson that one of those 21
would break ranks
and buzzby's been silent all weekend
yeah right so if this was something
where he had to change a heart he would
have said something i would think based
upon his past
past history but
i i just that to me is the biggest point
of curiosity is it one of his 21
clients or is it someone else because if
it is someone else to me it just has a
different feel yeah i i agree i mean it
does it would have a different feel for
me too if it was somebody outside of
that box of where you just go whoa wait
this person's
you know like you said they're out
they're in it for justice
uh that would be a little bit more that
type of justice yeah right
you get civil justice yes right
criminal justice yes that's the type to
only focus on criminal when the civil
justice train is already rolling right
that to me it obviously feels different
the whole thing feels different now
there's a criminal case definitely
definitely i mean it kind of takes like
you know the the the selfish aspect out
of it to where you're like are they
doing this for themselves or what so
that's where it would you know carry a
little bit more weight i mean what are
the positives for watson
right like with this i mean you know i
know they say they welcome this type of
thing but like ultimately why wha what
does it really help them with
as far as you know his defense here with
rusty hardin
if they are convinced that he did
nothing wrong and that's what watson has
said repeatedly from the get-go and
there's been no opportunity to prove any
of these allegations other than the back
and forth in the court of public opinion
that ultimately means nothing from rusty
hardin's perspective this is how you
talk this is what you say when you're
trying to convince people your client is
innocent we welcome the investigation
and we will fully cooperate
to the extent that there is still an
ongoing effort to score points in the
court of public opinion and surely there
is that's what you have to say now how
cooperative will they really be
we'll see and if they're not cooperative
it's not like somebody from the houston
police department or maybe they will i
don't know i don't know anything about
the inner workings of the hpd yeah but
let's say they're not all that
cooperative are they going to leak to
somebody well you know they said they
were going to be cooperative but they're
really not cooperative so
the the bottom line is
this thing gets more complicated as time
passes not less complicated and it's
something that the nfl at some point
is going to have to deal with and you
know roger goodell had a press
conference last week
in connection with the expansion of the
regular season to 17 games and look that
process
it's there's only so many people who can
make their way through to ask a question
nobody asked any questions about desean
watson and i don't know what he would
have said anyway but the chances of him
not being asked about desean watson in
the run-up to the draft right there
there's going to be other opportunities
and there's going to be more and more
questions i sent an email to the league
on saturday saying do you have an
updated comment now there's a criminal
case nothing sent it again yesterday
nothing going to send it again after the
show today at some point they have to
say something because the filing the
criminal case changes things and there's
there's
there's a
an issue that the nfl is going to have
to deal with unless this somehow gets
wrapped up and resolved before the start
of training camp this is something the
nfl is going to have to deal with chris
yeah i mean
definitely i mean the the houston texans
are going to have to deal with it i mean
i i mean if you're the houston texans at
this point i think you got to start like
thinking about
arrangements for life after desean or
wherever that may i mean whatever it is
i mean
to me like i just i feel like it's over
it's over no matter what now in houston
with with deshawn watson i don't know
that's the way i feel i just feel like
even if okay whatever this whole
situation gets figured out i can't
imagine these two coming together and
being like all right let's wipe it all
you know under the bridge here and let's
go back to the way things were like
to me it's it's got to be to that point
a little bit in houston where you got to
start thinking like all right life after
desean he's not going to be here we have
no idea where this whole the civil
complaints or the criminal charges or
anything are going to go either way
i would think he's going to get
suspended at some point and this isn't
going to make things any you know rosier
or anything like that with a rocky
relationship to begin with so
that's where i look at it and just go
it's over and they need to start making
plans you know otherwise to to move
forward with their future
strangest possible outcome yeah to this
would be
watson realizes he's destined for the
commissioner exempt list
so he shows up and reports
to the texans this year
and they pay him 10 million dollars to
not play in 2021. that would be the
strangest possible outcome
and that may be the only way he gets
paid by anyone this year at a time when
he's going to need the resources to pay
for his lawyer and to maybe resolve
these cases through settlement so that
that's that's what's crazy that's what's
hovering over this the possibility that
the team he has no interest in playing
for
may end up paying him
to not play in 2021 i i still think
there's a sentiment out there that he he
he that this is like gonna go away in
the nfl i'm telling you i know i don't
either mike i'm just telling you that
there's there is a sentiment of people
out there that have i think a little bit
just go wait what's really going to
happen as like questions you brought up
like he's not going to jail for any of
the things we've seen so far you can't
do that so i think there's a little bit
of that and i also think there's a
little bit of thought and lack of a
better way to say this is it's just some
young horny dude all right with a fetish
all right yeah
and again i don't look at it that way
either obviously it's more serious but i
i've i've heard that type of talk and
yeah well but that talks misinformed but
that's
informed i know this is a serious matter
right with 21 lawsuits filed a criminal
complaint filed it's not going away
quickly and anyone who thinks it is is
grossly misinformed this is hanging
around and every time watson's camp
thinks they found a silver bullet to
some respect it ends up being a
boomerang this is not maze that he's
going to get out of easily and the
sooner he accepts it
the sooner he lays the foundation to
maybe somehow find an appropriate
resolution right before training camp
opens although i think with each passing
day that becomes more and more difficult
to accomplish so anyone out there that
thinks this is just going to be gone
it's not it's i i would bet the over on
the amount of time that this is going to
continue to hover for deshaun watson for
the nfl for the texans and for the
individuals who are seeking justice
whether in the civil system or the
criminal system
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports